over the course of a hot day the
temperature rose by two and one-fourth
degrees every hour at dawn the
temperature was 72 degrees an expression
giving the temperature t the expression
giving the temperature T hours after
dawn is two and one fourths T plus 72
what was the temperature after six hours
so essentially they summarize this
information in the first two sentences
the temperature rises by two and
one-fourth degrees every hour that's
this part of the statement right over
here at dawn the temperature was 72
degrees so you're starting at 72 so
they're summarizing this equation right
here so when they say what was the
temperature after six hours we really
just have to substitute T equals 6 into
this expression to get the temperature
so we just need to evaluate this
expression at t is equal to 6 so it
becomes two and one-fourth two and
one-fourth times 6 plus plus 72 now
order of operations you want to do
multiplication before you do addition so
we have to want we want to multiply the
two and one-fourth times the 6 first and
the easier way to do that is to turn
this mixed number into an improper
fraction so this is a mixed number
because it obviously has one part that's
not a fraction one part that is a mixed
not an improper fraction will hat it'll
be a fraction but the numerator will be
larger than the denominator and to
convert it we take 4 times 2 and then
add 1 so four times two is eight plus 1
is 9 so this becomes 9 over 4 times 6 we
can write six as 6 over 1 plus 72 and
just to make sure you understand how
this worked 2 is the same thing as let
me write this over here two and one for
this is equal to 2 plus one-fourth which
is the same thing if you put a common
denominator what is 22 is 8 over 4 plus
one-fourth and so this is equal to 9
over for a quick way to do it is you
realize that too is going to become 8
over 4 and you can think about that just
by multiplying it by 4 2 times 4 is 8
and then you're going to add it to this
one over here to get 9 over 4 once you
get some practice you'll just kind of do
that in your head and so this becomes
multiplying fractions is is actually
less painful than adding them so we get
and we actually even before we multiply
this we can reduce our answer a little
bit we can divide our eventual numerator
and our eventual denominator by 2 so you
divide the six by 2 you get a 3 divide
the 4 by 2 you get a 2 so it'll become 9
x 39 times 3 over 2 so this is going to
become 27 27 over 2 that's this part
right over here plus plus 72 now we can
convert this right here back into a
mixed number two goes into let me do it
over here on the side so if you wanted
to convert this into a mixed number you
take 2 into we take 2 into 27 2 goes
into well 2 goes into two one time one
times two is two you subtract get a zero
bring down the 72 goes into seven three
times three times two is six subtract we
have a remainder 1 we could keep going
and turn this into a decimal but we just
want to turn into a mixed number so this
becomes right over here this part right
over here is 13 with a remainder 1 so
it's 13 and one half plus 72 plus 72
which is equal to it's going to be
something and a half is going to be 72
plus 13 and then another half so let's
see 72 plus 3 would give us a 75-72 plus
13 we goes to 85 so it's going to be 85
and a half 85 and one half and we are
done the temperature is 85 and a half or
85.5 if you used if you turn this into a
decimal 85.5 degrees or eighty five and
a half degree after six hours